même si ça n'est pas la grande affluence
il ya quand même un peu de monde sur
l'île de bréhat par exemple la
population peut passer pendant l'été de
300 à 6000 habitants pour le seul
médecin de ligne alors pas d'alternative
il faut se démultiplier audrey goasguen
et jean yves blanc ici en espadrilles
on fait du vélo et puis du bateau bref
bye bye boulot bré à trois kilomètres de
long une petite île paradisiaque cerclé
de granit rose où il fait bon vivre
enfin ça c'est la version pour les
touristes parce que s'il y en a un qui
ne chôme pas pendant l'été c'est cet
homme
oui nos moutons turquie
c'est ce qui se passe à une île galtier
et le nouveau médecin lille installée de
6 novembre des ruines il vit sa première
saison touristique
il a dû apprendre à diagnostiquer sous
les parasols à l'enfant qui a marché sur
un morceau de verre brisé dans la vase
temps qui sait il s'est enlevé un bon
morceau du talon malheureusement c'est
pas très grave
enfin y avoir du mal à marcher pendant
quelques jours quand même vrai à 300
habitants l'hiver et 6000 l'été autant
dire que pour lionel ça fait un peu de
changements
e
l'été on est quand même confrontée à une
population très diverse des gens qui
n'ont pas forcément la même perception
de l'offre de soins que les habitants
permanents inquiets qu'ils veulent
beaucoup de disponibilité beaucoup
d'astreinte
donc ça c'est plutôt un peu difficile et
puis ce qui est plaisant c'est que on
bouge beaucoup
donc cet actif les romains a fait une
chute de vélo
il fait partie des nombreux patients qui
vont se succéder dans le cabinet durant
tout l'été
point positif de 10 mille francs en
hiver le salaire du médecin ici face à
plus de 40 mille francs on était sur un
revers de la médaille ne pas rechigner à
la tâche même si elle est parfois un ton
grave c'est ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler
la bobologie mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de chutes beaucoup de petits
accidents alors il est bien il faut être
un peu tout vous faut être infirmière
pour faire des pansements pas de quoi
essayer d'en faire parce que c'est vrai
que c'est pas trop de spécialité ici on
fait du vélo et puis du bateau
finalement à bréhat
il fait bon être qu'un simple vacanciers
histoire de se laisser dorloter